si va bien este regreso a clase
recordemos que son más de 12 millones de
alumnos los que hoy vuelven al colegio
en francia- pero la práctica no es así
pues muchos colegios y liceos han
organizado todo para que la vuelta sea
escalonada durante toda esta semana y se
pueda respetar la distancia social hay
mucha emoción de parte de los alumnos ya
que recordemos muchos de ellos
estuvieron meses confinados y solo
volvieron al colegio dos semanas antes
de las vacaciones por lo tanto tenían
ganas de ver a sus amigos aunque este es
un regreso particular a ustedes ya lo
saben a partir de los 11 años el uso de
la mascarilla es obligatoria y no solo
en la sala de clase también en el patio
a la hora del recreo en la cantina a la
hora de comer incluso en las clases de
música el único lugar donde no es
obligatorio es en las clases de
educación física donde en cambio se debe
respetar dos metros de distancia entre
cada alumno si eso no es posible esas
clases no van a tener lugar también hay
tranquilidad de parte de los padres que
la mayoría de ellos han vuelto a
trabajar de manera presencial y
necesitan dejar a sus niños en el
colegio con los que pudimos hablar nos
dijeron que no tienen angustia por el
tema sanitario en realidad la emoción
era simplemente el regreso
los niños por eso muchos padres están
afuera de este colegio por ejemplo
esperando a sus hijos sino el gobierno
ha dicho que todas las medidas están
tomadas para que en caso de detección de
un caso de kobe 19 en una escuela ésta
sea cerrada y se establezca el sistema
de educación a distancia